This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个I-Heart播客节目。绝对真人。嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收看《艰难抉择》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯。这个节目探讨的是黑人男性的经历，进行一些在其他地方真不适合进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一位懂行的持证专业人士对话。有多少男人随身带着一套铠甲。这向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着你必须这么做，只要去听就懂了。
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
在AHA电台应用、苹果播客或你收听播客的任何地方收听《艰难抉择》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你曾多次篡改这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《被困之爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《被困之爱》播客。2%。这是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些困难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即TWA percent，在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约过后，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说
that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Before we jump in, I just want to note this episode involves discussions around sex, so listener discretion is advised. Hello everybody, welcome back to the show, welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners. It is so amazing to have you here back for another episode, one that I am very, very excited about.
相信你的女朋友。在Iheart radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《相信女朋友，相信我，宝贝》。欢迎回到《你二十多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们讨论二十多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理学的意义。在我们深入探讨之前，我只想说明本集涉及有关性的话题，因此建议听众自行斟酌。大家好，欢迎回到节目，欢迎回到播客，新听众，老听众。非常高兴你能来到这里收听另一期节目，这一期我非常非常激动。
We have a very special guest coming on board who I will introduce to you soon. but today we're going to talk about hookup culture in our 20s. It is so relevant. Our 20s are a time for sexual exploration, casual dating, casual hookups. I think for most of us, I would say we have had some experience in this area, be that just making out with someone at a party or something more intimate. It is, I would say, a fairly normal part of growing up, of our learning experience, discovering what we like, what our limits are, what we're into, what kind of dating we enjoy,
我们有一位非常特别的嘉宾即将登场，我稍后会向你们介绍她。但今天我们要讨论的是我们二十多岁的约炮文化。这太切合实际了。我们的二十多岁是进行性探索、随性约会、随性约炮的时期。我想对于我们大多数人来说，可以说我们在这一领域都有过一些经验，不管只是在派对上和某人热吻还是更亲密的事情。可以说，这是成长过程中相当正常的一部分，是我们的学习体验，探索我们喜欢什么，我们的极限在哪里，我们喜欢什么，我们喜欢什么样的约会，
what kind of relationships we enjoy. But maybe, like me, you come out of it feeling kind of worthless, maybe wanting more. It's definitely not for everyone. And I really want to talk about how hookup culture doesn't always line up to that empowered ideology we've been told. It's obviously an entirely personal preference, so no need to be ashamed of, if you are a fan of hookup culture, if you're not, it is for everyone to make their own opinion. And as Louise, our guest always says everything today is delivered in a sex positive way. Do what you want. We're not here to shame anyone.
我们喜欢什么样的关系。但也许和我一样，你从中走出来时感觉自己毫无价值，也许想要更多。这绝对不适合每个人。我真的很想谈谈为什么约炮文化并不总是符合我们被告知的那种赋权意识形态。这显然完全是个人的偏好，所以如果你是约炮文化的粉丝，就不必感到羞耻，如果你不是，每个人都有权形成自己的看法。就像我们的嘉宾路易斯总是说的那样，今天的一切都是以一种对性持积极态度的态度传递的。做你想做的事。我们不是来羞辱任何人的。
More so just kind of explore this kind of dynamic and the cultural, sexual phenomena of hookup culture and kind of deep dive into the psychology. So we're going to talk about the oral. origins of hookup culture, how it has emerged from many social and cultural transitions, why some people are more into hookups in casual sex than others, how it makes us feel, our brains on casual sex, and how you can go about navigating the sometimes complicated terrain of hookup culture. But without further ado, I would love to introduce our honoured, on a special guest, Louise, would you like to say hi? Hi, everyone. Thank you so much for having me on your podcast. I am so, so enamored and obsessed by all of the work you do. And just to everyone
更多的是去探索这种动态以及约炮文化的文化、性现象，并深入研究心理学。所以我们将讨论约炮文化的起源，它是如何从许多社会和文化转变中产生的，为什么有些人比其他人更热衷于约炮和随性性行为，它给我们带来的感觉，我们大脑对随性性行为的反应，以及你如何应对有时复杂的约炮文化领域。但话不多说，我很想隆重介绍我们的特邀嘉宾路易斯，你想打个招呼吗？大家好。非常感谢邀请我上你的播客。我非常非常倾倒于也着迷于你所做的一切工作。并且对于所有
listening, I think it's so cool that you're listening. I think there is nothing sexier, cooler, more amazing than like doing the self-work and looking inwards. So I'm so excited to go on this journey with you today. I have so much to share. It's going to be a fun one. And I love how you bring the science and the psychology and all of the sources, you know, very trustworthy, reliable. So can't wait and thank you. Yeah, I am so excited. I feel like we're going to have a bit of an overshare today. For those of you who don't know, Louise, is the host of an incredible podcast called Open House
在收听的听众，我认为你们在收听真的太酷了。我认为没有什么比进行自我剖析和向内看更性感、更酷、更神奇的了。所以我很高兴今天能和你一起踏上这段旅程。我有太多的分享。这将是一次有趣的经历。我喜欢你如何引入科学、心理学和所有的资料来源，你知道的，非常值得信赖、可靠。所以迫不及待了，谢谢你。是的，我太兴奋了。我觉得我们今天会有很多过度分享。对于那些不了解路易斯的人来说，她是一个名为《开放之家》的精彩播客的主持人
or the Open House podcast. You talk a lot about, you know, the intersections between relationships and you talk about therapy, you talk about sex, you talk about pop culture, so many amazing things. So I think you are the perfect guest for this episode. Thank you. Yeah, I've definitely got a lot of stories in the dating world, the sex world, the good, the bad, the sad. You know, I've cried so many times after sex. Like, we're going to just get into the realities today.
或《开放之家》播客。你谈了很多关于关系之间的交集，你谈论治疗，你谈论性，你谈论流行文化，还有很多精彩的事情。所以我认为你是这一期节目的完美嘉宾。谢谢。是的，我在约会世界、性世界里绝对有很多故事，有好的、坏的、悲伤的。你知道的，我在性爱后哭过很多次。所以我们今天就要切入现实。
But also the beautiful. I think we're going to cover everything. And I'm really excited to see where this goes with you today. Yeah. Well, I think that's one of those things, right? where we all know that hookup culture is part of our, even our teenage years, but definitely our 20s for those of us who choose to partake, as I know that both you and I have at various points in our life.
还有美好的一面。我想我们将涵盖所有内容。我真的很期待看看今天和你一起探讨这个话题会走向何方。是的。嗯，我认为这是那些事情之一，对吧？我们都知道约炮文化是我们青少年时期的一部分，但对于我们这些选择参与的人来说，绝对是我们二十多岁的一部分，正如我所知，你和我都在生命中的不同阶段参与过。
But there is still, I think, some stigma, but also not always a clear or a bit of an ambiguous understanding around what it does to our brains, why we leave certain casual, sexual dating interactions, feeling really worthless about ourselves. But I think it's also important to acknowledge that we have experienced these massive cultural and societal shifts recently. You know, it previously used to be that casual sex was not permissible. You got married, you had children, if you were a heteroperson, and you had sex within the confines of a married relationship. and there has been that massive shift recently. Like, I'm sure that's something you can speak to as well.
但我认为仍然存在一些污名化，而且对于它对我们的大脑有什么影响、为什么我们在经历某些随性、性的约会互动后对自己感到非常没有价值，并不总是有清晰或有点模棱两可的理解。但我认为同样重要的是要承认，我们最近经历了这些巨大的文化和社会转变。你知道，以前随性性行为是不被允许的。如果你是一个异性恋者，你结婚，生孩子，并且在婚姻关系的范围内发生性行为。而最近发生了巨大的转变。就像，我相信这也是你可以谈论的事情。
Like, what do you think some of those major reasons are behind why this process has kind of taken place? Definitely. I mean, you're right with the massive social and cultural shifts. And I think that so much of that has been driven by not only like the sexual liberation move in the 60s where people started to really, you know, let go of those constraints that people had lived with for so long and moved. more into this space of freedom and love and also like acceptance of their bodies and really
就像，你认为发生这种过程背后的一些主要原因是什么？当然。我的意思是，你说得对，伴随着巨大的社会和文化转变。我认为其中很大一部分不仅是由60年代的性解放运动推动的，当时人们开始真正地，你知道的，放下人们长期以来赖以生存的束缚，转向更多地进入自由、爱以及对自己身体的接纳的空间，并真正地
like leaning into that which I think is really beautiful. I think that set the foundations for this but there's still stigma around that right if you look back at the 1960s you know it's like oh flower power like everyone was like having sex with everyone like the way that we talk about it is still with an angle or like a lens of shame which I think is so interesting but what I also think is so interesting is that I think that culture today has romanticized and fantasized all of this. Like if you watch a movie, they fall in love, they kiss, they have sex, you never hear them talking about like, do you want to do this? Like, have you got protection?
倾向于这一点，我觉得这真的很美。我认为这为此奠定了基础，但周围仍然存在污名化，对吧？如果你回顾20世纪60年代，你知道，就像“花朵力量”，每个人都好像在和所有人发生性关系——我们谈论它的方式仍然带有羞耻的角度或视角，我觉得这非常有趣。但我也觉得非常有趣的是，今天的文化已经把所有这一切浪漫化和幻想化了。如果你看电影，他们坠入爱河，接吻，发生性关系，你永远不会听到他们谈论诸如：你想这样做吗？你有保护措施吗？
Like, what are we going to be after this? You never see any of these discussions. It's just this romance whirlwind. And, you know, we just have picked that up from as young as we can remember with every. every movie, every relationship, celebrity relationship that we've ever looked at. I just feel like the media around us has sort of romanticized this whole hookup culture. And sometimes the truth is that it isn't quite as romantic as we want it to be. I totally agree.
事后我们要干什么？你从看不到任何这样的讨论。这只是一场浪漫的旋风。而且，你知道，我们从记事起，从每一部电影、每一段关系、我们见过的每一段名人关系中，就已经接受了这一点。我只是觉得我们周围的媒体把整个约炮文化浪漫化了。有时事实是，它并不像我们希望的那样浪漫。我完全同意。
And like the point you make about how the media, like we get a lot of our sexual education from the media. But I think you have an amazing point. Right. We had that sexual revolution. Birth control became more accessible. so you didn't have to worry about unwanted pregnancies out of wedlock. But I feel like we still have those very traditional concepts about what a relationship should look like. We're still very much a monogamous society.
正如你所指出的，媒体，我们在很大程度上从媒体获得性教育。但我认为你提出了一个了不起的观点。对。我们经历了那场性革命。避孕措施变得更容易获得，所以你不必担心婚外意外怀孕。但我觉得我们仍然对关系应该是什么样有着非常传统的概念。我们在很大程度上仍然是一个一夫一妻制的社会。
The majority of us would say that we want a monogamous relationship. We think about marriage. We want to have children in a stable relationship. That's still something that's very much ingrained within us. but our kind of values and our attitudes towards sex haven't, have kind of sped up a little bit further in that process. And we haven't really been able to catch up in that sense. And it's all been, like you said, actually, romanticised by these movies,
我们大多数人会说我们想要一夫一妻制的关系。我们考虑婚姻。我们想在稳定的关系中生孩子。这仍然是我们根深蒂固的东西。但我们对性的态度和价值观在某种程度上在这个过程中走得更远了一点。我们在那种意义上并没有真正赶上。这一切都像你所说的那样，实际上被这些电影浪漫化了，
which show like someone falling onto the bed with their like really hot movie star partner. They just met in the bar and like they just like have this crazy sex and it's always really, really good and really fulfilling. I don't think I have ever seen a scene in a TV show in a movie where there has been the like, what are we conversation? Never. Or like someone's been like talking to their friends around like, oh, like I hooked up with this guy once and now I like have lots of regrets
电影里展示了某人倒在床上，身边是他们那个超级火辣的电影明星伴侣。他们刚刚在酒吧相遇，然后他们就发生了疯狂的性行为，而且总是非常非常美好，非常满足。我想我从来没有在电视剧或电影中看到过这样一个场景，里面有“我们在算什么关系”的对话。从来没有。或者就像某人一直在和他们的朋友谈论，哦，我曾经和这个家伙约过炮，现在我有满心的遗憾
or I feel really bad. And, you know, most of the time their friends are like, oh yeah, like single girl sleigh. Like, oh, like go for it. Like you've left your husband, whatever. There's all these tropes around it. And we haven't really caught up to that. And like, I know that you spoke about this before and we've spoken about this before.
或者我感觉很糟糕。而且，大多数时候他们的朋友都会说，哦，是的，单身女孩太棒了。哦，冲吧。就像你离开了你的丈夫，诸如此类。周围有很多这样的老套路。我们还没有真正赶上这一点。而且，我知道你之前说过这个，我们也之前讨论过。
But casual sex or casual even just like hookups, like making out with someone, like cuddling someone, doing anything else, can leave us feeling kind of empty in a way that isn't always seen in kind of the glamorized movies that we've watched since children. Yeah. And just to build on that, because you mentioned cuddling. And I think this is one of the things that I've done a lot in my own therapy. but also spoken about on my podcast is that often I find, and I don't know if you've experienced this, that sometimes, honestly, looking back at a hookup, all I actually wanted was a cuddle.
但随性性行为或随性的约炮，比如和某人热吻、和某人依偎、做任何其他事情，都会让我们感到一种空虚感，这种空虚感并不总是像我们从小看到的那种被美化的电影中那样。是的。在此基础上再补充一点，因为你提到了依偎。我想这是我在自己的治疗中做过很多的事情之一，
Like sometimes all I wanted was like some intimacy to maybe just be making out with them. You know, it's so fun to be like hooking up with someone in a bar or on a night out or on a date or whatever that is. And then sometimes everything sort of just runs away with you and everything picks up speed and you don't really know this person. and then it's kind of hard to have that conversation before it happens, much like you said.
但也曾在我的播客中谈到过，我经常发现——我不知道你是否经历过这种情况——有时，老实说，回顾一次约炮，我其实想要的只是一个拥抱。就像有时我想要的只是一些亲密感，也许只是和他们热吻。你知道，在酒吧里、在夜生活、在约会或任何类似的情况下和某人约炮是很有趣的。然后有时一切都失控了，一切都在加速，你并不真正认识这个人，
And then it happens, whatever it is, whatever part of the encounter that is. And then the next day, all of a sudden, you wake up to the stark reality of, oh, my goodness, you know, that actually, all I wanted was a cuddle and some attention. And then the next day you feel like really empty. And I think at some point maybe we can go into what that empty feeling is because everyone says, oh, I feel empty or I felt used. The truth is there's so much behind that. And it's a really, really important thing for us to just all unpack.
然后很难在事情发生之前进行那种对话，就像你说的。然后它发生了，无论是什么，无论那次邂逅的哪一部分。然后第二天，突然之间，你醒来面对严酷的现实：哦，天哪，你知道，其实我想要的只是一个拥抱和一些关注。然后第二天你会觉得非常空虚。我想在某个时候也许我们可以探讨一下那种空虚感是什么，因为每个人都说，哦，我觉得空虚，或者我觉得被利用了。事实是，这背后的原因很多。这是我们所有人都需要解开的一个非常非常重要的事情。
And sometimes you're right. You just want to cuddle. And I think there is this expectation, right, because we've become more sexually liberated, which is an amazing, amazing thing. But there is always this expectation of like, okay, intimacy equals sex now. Intimacy equals some form of like, yeah, sexual encounter,
有时你是对的。你只是想要一个拥抱。我认为这里有一种期望，对吧？因为我们变得更加性解放了，这是一件了不起的、了不起的事情。但总是存在这样一种期望，即：好吧，现在亲密等于性。亲密等于某种形式的，是的，性接触，
which sometimes it's like, we actually don't want that from someone. We actually want platonic intimacy or we want some of the form of intimacy. And I think it's also worth acknowledging if you're listening to this being like, no part of casual sex sounds good to me. Or maybe you're someone who's like, oh, I love casual sex. This is super fulfilling. That's also totally normal because I think people are really different in kind of what we desire
有时我们的感觉是：我们实际上并不希望从别人那里得到这个。我们实际上想要柏拉图式的亲密感，或者我们想要某种其他形式的亲密感。我想这也值得承认，如果你听到这里觉得：随性性行为的任何部分对我都听起来不好。或者也许你是那种觉得：哦，我喜欢随性性行为。这超级充实。这也是完全正常的，因为我认为人们在
from our sex lives, what we desire from our romantic kind of person. suits. I was telling the ways earlier about this personality measure called sociosexuality. And it kind of measures whether someone is going to be more inclined to engage in casual sex. And it's a personality feature that each of us have, that we sit on a spectrum. So I have friends, I'm sure you have friends the ways, or maybe I've even been this person at a point in my life where like casual sex, short-term relationships, no commitment. That was something that was super interesting to me and something that I was like, yeah, I'm a big fan of this. But then there are other people who are like, oh, this actually isn't where I stand.
从我们的性生活中渴望什么、从我们的浪漫伴侣中渴望什么方面有很大不同。我之前跟路易斯谈过这种叫做“社会性爱倾向”（sociosexuality）的人格测量指标。它用来衡量某人是否更倾向于进行随性性行为。这是我们每个人都具有的人格特征，我们处于一个光谱上。所以我有朋友，我确信你有朋友，或者甚至我自己在我生命中的某个阶段也曾是这样的人，那时随性性行为、短期关系、没有承诺。那对我来说超级有趣，我觉得，是的，我是这个的大力支持者。但也有其他人觉得，哦，这实际上不是我的立场。
This is not what I'm looking for when I go into these interactions, which is like kind of shit when you're like, oh, maybe I actually didn't want to do this. But the other person, you know, there was this like expectation or like kind of like this societal pressure. Like I think we've almost turned away from slut shaming, of course, that still exists into this very like sex is empowering. So you should be having heaps of sex. And if you're not having heaps of sex, like there's something about you that's undesirable. Like have you found that as well,
这不是我进行这些互动时所寻找的，这有点糟糕，当你觉得：哦，也许我其实不想这样做。但另一个人，你知道，存在这种期望或者某种社会压力。就像我认为我们几乎已经从羞辱荡妇（当然这仍然存在）转向了这种非常“性是赋予力量的”态度。所以你应该有很多性生活。如果你没有很多的性生活，那就说明你有什么不受欢迎的地方。你也有这种感觉吗？
like within your friendship group or within your own life? Yeah, I think it's so important to touch on this point of sexual liberation. And, you know, with the rise of feminism, like you said, with the rise of birth control, there is this space where we are stepping into a more empowered space where it's like, oh, why should men be able to sleep with, 10 people and no one bat an eyelid, 100 people and no on bat an eyelid, you know, more. Whatever that number is, there's very little judging around the man and they might just be like,
在你的朋友圈里还是在你自己的生活中？是的，我认为触及性解放这一点非常重要。而且，你知道的，随着女权主义的兴起，正如你所说的，随着避孕药的普及，存在这样一个空间，我们正在迈向一个更有力量的空间，就像，哦，为什么男人可以和10个人上床，没有人眨一下眼睛，100个人上床没有人眨一下眼睛，甚至更多。
oh, they're a fuck boy. Sorry, I don't know if you swear on your podcast. No, go for it. Okay, perfect. You know, oh, they're a fuck boy. But then there's also this kind of mentality that if they're the fuck boy, they're kind of attractive and everyone's into them and everyone wants them. Whereas like, that does not happen for us. And I think that it's just really interesting that You know, if you look back to like Bridgeton, say, if you've watched that TV program, the whole thing in that is that you're waiting to be chosen by the man. You know, the room full of women, you're waiting to be chosen. We're moving away from that today where you're right, empowerment, female empowerment.
哦，他们就是个渣男。抱歉，我不知道你们播客能不能说脏话。没事，随便说。好的，完美。你知道的，哦，他们是个渣男。但同时也有这样一种心态，就是如果他们是渣男，他们反而挺有吸引力的，每个人都迷恋他们，每个人都想要他们。然而，这并没有发生在我们身上。我觉得很有意思的是，你知道的，如果你回看像《布里杰顿》这样的剧，如果你看过那个电视节目的话，整部剧的核心就是你在等待被男人挑选。你知道的，满屋子的女人，你在等待被挑选。而今天我们正在摆脱那种模式，你说得对，是赋权，女性赋权。
We can do whatever we want. And so we should be able to. But the truth is, is that underneath that empowerment, I still don't think we're having the truthful discussions around what do I actually want here. And like you said, that point around intimacy is you might just want to cuddle or you might want to hook up but not have penetrative sex or because, you know, for me, I'm, well, I'm in a relationship now, but before I would have been way more happy having a hookup that didn't involve penetrative sex because for me, I have more trauma around that and I want to know someone and feel safe with them. But I'd happily do other stuff. And then I have friends who would sleep with a different guy every weekend and it would. it wouldn't phase them at all.
我们可以做任何我们想做的事。我们也本该如此。但事实是，在这种赋权表象之下，我认为我们仍然没有进行真正坦诚的讨论，去探讨我在这里究竟想要什么。就像你说的，关于亲密关系的那一点，你可能只是想抱一抱，或者你可能只想发生性吸引但不要实质性性行为，因为，你知道的，对我来说，好吧，我现在处于一段恋爱关系中，但在那之前，我会更乐意进行不涉及实质性性行为的亲密接触，因为对我来说，我在那方面有更多的心理创伤，我想了解一个人并在他身边感到安全。但我很乐意做其他事情。然后我有些朋友，她们每个周末都会和不同的男生上床，而且这完全不会对她们产生任何影响。
There would be no negative emotions coming up. So you're right. We're all so different and so unique. And I think it's just about being really compassionate with our own story. Because often we do have our own sex story. And often it does come from a real place of pain and not being respected or doing things we didn't want to do or regret or shame or guilt. And when we are just a little bit clearer and more compassionate with our own truth,
不会产生任何负面情绪。所以你说得对。我们都是如此不同，如此独特。我觉得这只是关于对我们自己的故事抱有真正的同理心。因为通常我们确实都有自己的情感经历。而且通常它确实源于真正的痛苦，源于未被尊重、做了我们不想做的事、或是源于遗憾、羞耻或内疚。当我们对自己真实的内心多一点清醒和同理心时，
I think we can then say it exactly like you said, what do I want from this? Do I actually just want a cuddle or a date and some flirting? And I think it can help us just manage those boundaries a little bit better. And I'm reminded of this quote I heard of the other day was like just because it's empowering doesn't mean it leaves you feeling empowered. Love that. Which I just think, yeah, it's so pertinent to this conversation, right?
我觉得我们就能像你刚才说的那样确切地表达出来：我从这件事中到底想要什么？我其实只是想要一个拥抱、一次约会和一些调情吗？我觉得这可以帮助我们更好地把握那些界限。我突然想起我前几天听到的这样一句话：仅仅因为一件事赋予了你力量，并不意味着它会让你感到充满力量。太棒了。我只是觉得，是的，这句话和我们今天的对话太贴切了，对吧？
It's like just because society has told you that, you know, I think we're specifically talking to women here, or people who identify as women, just because society has told you that to be empowered, you should be having casual sex, you should be reclaiming the sexual narrative that has very much and historically, very much been in the favor of men,
就像仅仅因为社会告诉你——你知道的，我觉得我们在这里主要是对女性说话，或者对认同为女性的人说话——仅仅因为社会告诉你，为了变得强大，你应该进行随意的性行为，你应该夺回那个在历史上一直偏向男性的性叙事，
doesn't mean that you personally have to be on board with that. Like there are other ways that you can feel liberated. And I feel like, sometimes sexual freedom gets confused with like sexual promiscuity, which is like super fair. Like I would say that I'm a fairly promiscuous person at this point in my life because that's my preference. I think Louise has given me a clap. I'm clapping just like mainly, mainly for your honesty. Because I feel like in my 20s like I'm older than you. I would never be able to sit on a podcast and say, oh yeah, I'm in my promiscuous phase because I held so much shame.
并不意味着你个人必须接受这一点。还有其他方式可以让你感到解放。我觉得，有时候性自由会被与性乱交混淆，这很正常。可以说，在我人生的这个阶段，我是一个相当随性的人，因为那是我的偏好。我觉得露易丝（Louise）好像在为我鼓掌。我鼓掌主要是为了、主要是为了你的诚实。因为我觉得在我二十多岁的时候——我比你大。我绝不可能坐在播客上说，哦，是的，我正处于我的放纵期，因为我背负了太多的羞耻感。
around being promiscuous because I did so many things and I felt so regretful. But now like I'm older, I'm exactly the same. That's why we're here talking about this. But just to hear you, hear you say that, I'm like, oh my goodness, this is a healthy queen. Like I love to hear it. I love to hear it. You made my day. But I think that it comes from like a point of like, okay, I'm in like whatever, my promiscuous error.
围绕着性乱交的羞耻感，因为我做了很多事，也感到非常遗憾。但现在我年龄大了，我完全一样。这就是为什么我们今天在这里谈论这个。但听到你、听到你这么说，我就觉得，哦天哪，这是一个健康的辣妹。我太喜欢听这个了。我太喜欢听这个了。你让我这一天都过得很开心。但我认为这源于一种心态，就是，好吧，管他呢，反正我正处于放纵期。
But the thing is that I'm not. And even then I would say that hook up culture still doesn't always benefit me. because you both have to be in the same mindset if you if this is a casual interaction for it to work. Like I've had so many interactions in which I know in my deepest of hearts that I am a, I'm a relationship girly. Like I in my long in my in my in my in the long run would love commitment, would love a partner, would love someone who I can trust and talk to. But at this point in my life, that's not something that's like is going to fit in with how busy I am with my schedule with my life priorities.
但问题是，其实我并没有。即便如此，我还是要说，约炮文化并不总是对我有益。因为如果这是一次随意的互动，要让它起作用，你们两个人的心态必须在同一频道上。我经历过很多次互动，在我的内心深处，我知道我是一个渴望恋爱的人。从长远来看，我渴望承诺，渴望一个伴侣，渴望一个我可以信任并向其倾诉的人。但在我人生的这个阶段，这并不符合我忙碌的日程安排和生活优先级。
but you know girls got to eat girls got to eat and we do have biological needs you know and it's really like how I think I think just to your point it's like what does empowerment mean to you what does empowerment mean to you like for me I've realized that empowerment means protecting my energy protecting my body until I feel safe enough with someone and understand the truth of their intentions
但你知道的，人总得吃饭，人总得吃饭，我们确实有生理需求，你知道的，这真的很像，我只是觉得，顺着你的话说，这就好像——对你来说“赋权”意味着什么？对你来说“赋权”意味着什么？就像对我而言，我意识到赋权意味着保护我的能量，保护我的身体，直到我对某个人感到足够的安全，并了解他们意图的真实性，
that I can then share my body with them share my pleasure with them share the experience with them And that for me is empowering. Whereas before when I was younger, I didn't have any of those things. So I always went into the promiscuous box rather than the sexually empowered. Like I wasn't sexually empowered or sexually liberated when I was younger. I was just being driven to promiscuity. I'm not even sure if that's a word by so, so many parts of me that were looking for love
然后我才能与他们分享我的身体，与他们分享我的快乐，与他们分享这段经历。对我来说，这才是真正的赋权。而以前当我更年轻的时候，我根本没有这些认知。所以我总是把自己塞进乱交的盒子，而不是真正获得性赋权的盒子。当我年轻的时候，我并不是获得了性赋权或性解放。我只是被我内心深处那么多寻找爱、
and looking for validation and looking for attention. And that's not, that's for me that wasn't empowering. And it really, really hurt me. But I think when you do the work and you start to do this work and the healing, you realize like, oh, yeah, I can do this in a more empowered way because empowered to me means X, Y, Z. And it's different for everyone. Oh, that's such a beautiful way of putting it. I feel like you're like a mentor to me.
寻找认可、寻找关注的部分所驱使。对我来说，那并不是赋权。那真的、真的深深伤害了我。但我觉得，当你做了内省的工作，开始进行这种心理建设和治愈时，你会意识到，哦，是的，我可以以一种更有力量的方式来做这件事，因为对我而言，“赋权”意味着X、Y、Z。而且这对每个人来说都是不同的。哦，你这样表达太美妙了。我觉得你就像我的导师一样。
You're like, I'm like your youngest self. But I feel like I'm coming out of it. Like, actually, I know this. Like, I went on this date with someone recently and it was like super casual. It was without giving detail. We love details. Yeah. Maybe later.
你就好像、我感觉自己就像你最年轻的时候。但我感觉我正在走出那个阶段。实际上，我知道这一点。就像我最近和某个人约会，过程非常随性。没有透露细节。我们最喜欢细节了。好吧。也许以后再说。
Maybe we do an R-rated cut of this. But it was a hookup, right? Whatever you want to apply to that. And I was like, yeah, I've done this before. Like, this is fun. And then, like, three days, like, for the next three days, I just was like, I actually just don't feel great about myself. I actually feel like I really liked this person.
也许我们会做一个限制级剪辑版。但那确实是一次约炮，对吧？无论你用什么词来定义它。当时我想，是的，我以前做过这种事。这挺有趣的。然后，接下来的三天里，我只是觉得，我其实对自己的感觉不太好。我其实觉得我真的很喜欢这个人。
And I would have actually really enjoyed getting to know. them. And I made that clear to them and they were like, oh, I didn't think that's what we were doing. And I was like, all right. I think that I've, yeah, I was like, that feels, yeah, yeah, literally, I was like, I was like, I just feels so awful. But I also was like, okay, like, I think I'm done here. Like, this, this actually isn't perhaps what I want. I think that although I was making those choices and although it like fit with, with the lifestyle I have right now and I'm quite young and I want to explore. And, you know, there's still a lot of stuff that I'm trying to deal with from previous
而且我其实会很享受去了解他。我把这一点明确告诉了他们，而他们的反应是，哦，我没想到我们是这种关系。当时我就想，好吧。我觉得我——是的，当时我就想，这感觉——是的，真的，当时我就想，这感觉太糟糕了。但同时我也觉得，好吧，我想我到此为止了。这、这其实也许并不是我想要的。我觉得尽管我当时做出了那些选择，尽管它符合我目前的生活方式，而且我还很年轻，我想要探索。并且，你知道的，我仍然有很多试图处理的来自过往的……
relationships that I think wouldn't be helpful to bring into a new relationship until that's resolved. It's important to kind of maybe know my boundaries around commitment. I still think it's one of those things where I was like, I, in some way, have come to think that having sex with someone casually is going or doing something with someone casually is going to make me feel better because in the past it's made me feel better and it no longer is doing that
恋情的问题，在这些问题解决之前，把它们带入一段新的恋情是没有帮助的。了解我对承诺的界限可能还是很重要的。我仍然觉得这是那种让我觉得——在某种程度上，我曾一度认为和某人随性地发生性行为，或者和某人随性地做点什么会让我感觉更好，因为过去它确实让我感觉更好，但现在它不再起作用了，
and like the more research I did into it and also just anecdotal experience the more I was like okay like the part of my brain that enjoys this now is growing up it's maturing I actually want to talk about this study because I think it's really interesting here which was a study done in the US
而且我对此做的研究越多，加上我个人的生活经验，我就越觉得，好吧，我大脑中享受这件事的那部分正在长大，正在成熟。我其实很想谈谈这项研究，因为我觉得它在这里真的非常有趣。这是在美国进行的一项研究，
and it interviewed both men and women the morning after hook up. Super fascinating. 82% of men were like, yep, pretty happy that I did that, glad that they'd done it. Only 57% of women. So like, I do also think it's a gendered thing in some ways as well, like feelings like regret are more likely to impact women, emotional difficulties, a sense of a loss of respect, even like difficulties with a steady partner in the future, our embarrassment, like none of that to scare anyone, but I think it's something that as you mature as well, and you realize that it's not all glamorous and romantic, you start to be like,
它在约炮的第二天早晨采访了男性和女性。非常吸引人。82%的男性表示，是的，对自己的所作所为相当高兴，很高兴自己做了这件事。只有57%的女性这么觉得。所以，我认为这在某种程度上也与性别有关，比如后悔这种情绪更有可能影响女性，情绪上的困难、失去自尊的感觉，甚至是未来与固定伴侣相处时的困难、尴尬——这并不是为了吓唬任何人，但我认为随着你的成熟，当你意识到这一切并不全是光鲜亮丽和浪漫的时候，你开始意识到，
oh, there are actually our emotional consequences to this. And it's okay to be someone who says, this isn't for me. Like, does that kind of relate to you? Like, did you have some of that experience as well when you moved out of your promiscuity era? Oh, my goodness, yes. And I think that is, it is such a gendered topic. I'm so glad you brought up that study because it is such a fascinating study. And I think that is the research that also said that more women than men hoped that a relationship would develop following a hookup. And that exactly. Yeah, and that they also identified more emotional involvement than the men. And I think it's so important that there's research being put behind these things because we always say, you know, we make these sweeping
哦，这背后其实是有情绪代价的。而且，一个人完全可以说“这不适合我”。这和你的经历有点像吗？当你走出放纵期时，你也有过一些这样的经历吗？哦，天哪，是的。而且我认为，这是一个非常具有性别色彩的话题。我很高兴你提到这项研究，因为这是一项非常迷人的研究。而且我认为，正是这项研究还指出，希望在约炮后发展出恋爱关系的女性多于男性，千真万确。是的，她们也比男性投入了更多的情感。我认为，在这些事情背后有研究支持是非常重要的，因为我们总是说，你知道的，我们会做出这些概括性的
generalizations like, oh, men love casual sex. Men find casual sex way easier than women. It's awesome to actually start to put some statistics behind that. And this ties me to my, point of silence, which is that what I find in general hookups, casual hookups, casual sex, is there's an element of silence, right? Like you said, you didn't communicate to this guy that you went on a date with before, maybe because you weren't aware at that point, or maybe because you didn't feel comfortable, you didn't want to come on too strong. You didn't communicate, like, hey, I'm super up for being intimate with you, but I kind of think that I'd also like this to maybe become something else, you know, how do you feel about that?
断言，比如，哦，男人喜欢随性性行为。男人觉得随性性行为比女人容易得多。能够开始为这些观点提供一些统计数据，真的很棒。这就让我想到了我刚才想要暂停讨论的一点，那就是我发现一般的约炮、随性的约炮、随性的性行为中，包含着一种沉默的元素，对吧？就像你说的，你没有和你之前约会的这个男生沟通，也许是因为你当时并没有意识到，也许是因为你觉得不舒服，不想表现得太强势。你没有沟通，比如，嘿，我很乐意和你亲密接触，但我其实觉得我也希望这段关系能变成别的什么，你知道的，你对此有什么看法？
And it's this element of silence. And if you have the hookup and you have silence, then what I find happens is we add our own meaning. We add our own intention and we add our own like story around their intention. And when I was younger, maybe when I was your age, they'd give me attention and I'd think it was intention. I'd be like, oh my gosh, this is going to be something. Like, oh my goodness, this, we might be boyfriend and a girlfriend. Like this might be something.
这就是沉默的成分。如果你发生了约炮并且保持沉默，那么我发现接下来发生的事情是，我们会赋予其我们自己的意义。我们会加入自己的意图，并围绕对方的意图编造我们自己的故事。当我年轻的时候，也许像你这个年纪，他们只要给我一点关注，我就会误以为那是真心意图。我会想，哦天哪，这会有后续的。就像，哦天哪，我们可能会成为男朋友和女朋友。这可能会发展成某种关系。
And, you know, with attachment wounds and attachment hunger as well, you also can end up going into the, oh my God, this is it. This is my person. Like, they're going to save everything. Yes. Yeah. Like, exactly. Oh, no. Honestly, I'm like, I've been there too.
而且，你知道的，伴侣依恋创伤和依恋饥渴也会导致你最终陷入这种想法：“哦天哪，就是他。这就是我的真命天子。他会拯救一切。”是的。没错。就像，真的。哦，不。老实说，我想说我也曾经历过。
So I'm like, no shame, no judgment. But it's that silence. When you have silence, we add our own meaning. And I just think it's so great that we're starting to have some of that research that you just pulled out there to start to just share the truth that yes, sometimes women maybe do experience. more emotional. Like emotional expectations almost. Yeah. Emotional expectations, emotional involvement, and maybe even emotional damage.
所以我只想说，这没什么好羞耻的，也不需要评判。但这就是沉默的代价。当存在沉默时，我们就会自己赋予意义。我真的觉得，我们开始借助你刚才列出的那些研究来分享真相，这真是太棒了：是的，有时女性确实会经历更多的情感波动。
That sounds a bit strong. But I think the research shows that like women get, they regret it more. They maybe feel more upset about it afterwards or guilty. And so I think it's important to talk about that. Yeah. And I think it also comes to this point of like sexes is, yeah, physical interaction. It's great. It feels amazing, but it's also very emotionally nuanced. And something, I think that's something that we should be aware of because I will just
这听起来可能有点夸张。但我觉得研究表明女性确实会感到更多的遗憾。她们事后可能会感到更心烦意乱或内疚。所以我觉得讨论这些是很重要的。是的。而且我觉得这也归结到这样一点，即性，是的，它是一种身体互动。这很棒，感觉棒极了，但它也具有非常复杂的情感细微差别。我认为这是我们应该意识到的一点，因为我只想
make a claim for like the positive impacts, which this study also found, which I think are worth noting, boosts in self-esteem, sexual pleasure, relaxation, it's a really great physical outlet. And one really interesting one was self-awareness, which I thought was really, really interesting when I was thinking about my own history where I was like from all of these casual hookups or even casual relationships I have taken an important lesson and I think it does teach you what you want like and I think that that's where I'm at at this point at this emotional turning point where I'm like this actually isn't what I want I feel like in some ways I have been slightly indoctrinated into thinking that it is and for many of my friends it is what they want I'm like
为它的积极影响说句公道话，这项研究也发现了这些影响，我认为值得一提：自信心的提升、性快感、放松，它是一个非常棒的身体宣泄渠道。其中一个非常有趣的点是自我意识，当我反思自己的过往时，我觉得这一点真的非常非常有趣。我发现，从所有这些随意的约炮甚至随意的关系中，我都汲取了重要的教训，我认为它确实教会了你你真正想要的是什么，而且我认为这就是我目前所处的状态，在这个情感转折点上，我意识到这其实并不是我想要的。我觉得在某种程度上，我被潜移默化地灌输了这种思想，认为这就是我想要的，而对于我的许多朋友来说，这确实是她们想要的，我想说，
power to you I cannot wait to live vicariously through all of the of your stories. But it's like sexes, I think sometimes can be, a lot of the emotions can be removed when we put it in a casual context, but that doesn't mean that the emotions aren't still lingering somewhere, right? Like it might not be committed, it might not be based in like very pure, ephemeral love. But with any intimate interaction, it's like, it's not like your brain is separate from your body here.
祝你们力量满满，我已经迫不及待地想通过你们的故事来进行精神体验了。但这就好像性，我觉得有时候，当我们把它放在一个随意的语境中时，许多情感可以被剥离，但这并不意味着情感依然没有在某个地方徘徊，对吧？它可能不是承诺型的，它可能不是建立在非常纯洁、转瞬即逝的爱情基础上的。但对于任何亲密互动来说，这就好像，你的大脑在这里并不独立于你的身体。
Like, there will be neurotransmitters that are. are fired. There will be interactions that are going on in your brain that you can't always control. One of those is that attachment that you talk about and how I think as a study shows, specifically women have this expectation of like, where is this going to go? I want more. Which I think is interesting when we talk about like the brain because we know sex feels great. We've said that a million times and casual sex is a great outlet, right? But sex also comes with a lot of physical and mental experiences, including the release of neurochemicals like oxytocin and dopamine.
比如，会有神经递质被激活。你的大脑中会发生你并不总能控制的互动。其中之一就是你所谈到的依恋，正如研究所显示的那样，女性尤其会有这种期望：这会走向何方？我想要更多。当我们谈论大脑时，我觉得这很有趣，因为我们知道性感觉很好。我们已经说过一百万遍了，随性的性行为是一个很好的宣泄渠道，对吧？但性也伴随着许多生理和心理体验，包括释放像催产素和多巴胺这样的神经化学物质。
And those hormones, those neurochemicals, they are important for things like bonding. And they're important for things like attachment, feeling safe, feeling secure. Those hormones do not understand the difference between casual sex and committed sex. Like if the pleasure is the same, it's going to respond the same, which is why sometimes we might have that feeling of hurt or of unrequited longing after we have encountered someone and done whatever with them.
而这些荷尔蒙、这些神经化学物质，对于建立连结之类的事情是很重要的。它们对于建立依恋、感到安全、感到安心之类的事情也很重要。这些荷尔蒙无法分清随性性行为和承诺性行为的区别。如果快感是一样的，它的反应就会是一样的，这就是为什么在我们与某人接触并和他们做了某些事情之后，有时我们可能会产生受伤的感觉或无法得到回应的渴望。
And it's not even necessarily sex that releases that. Like things like oxytocin, it can literally be released from, you know, holding hands with someone or getting a really nice hug like we talked about before. but you think it's why people naturally get attached, especially if you haven't, you know, especially if something that you've done with a partner is like bringing you a lot of joy, suddenly you can find that even against your will, you have this like connection with this person.
甚至不一定是性行为才会释放这些物质。像催产素这样的东西，字面意义上可以通过和某人手牵手，或者像我们之前谈到的那样得到一个非常温暖的拥抱来释放。但你认为这就是为什么人们会自然而然地产生依恋，特别是如果你没有——特别是如果你和伴侣做的事情带给你很多快乐，突然之间你会发现，即使违背你的意愿，你也会和这个人产生这种联系。
I don't know if you've had this way you've been like, I knew this was casual, I knew this was casual, but still you're like waiting for the text, or still you're like, oh, what more is going to come from this? I am so glad you brought up waiting for the text because I think it's really important that we talk about cortisol in this like formula as well because you're right you know our oxytocin is soaring because our body is bonding physically and it thinks we're going to bond more and there's
我不知道你是否也有过这种感觉，你会想，我知道这只是逢场作戏，我知道这只是随性而为，但你还是会忍不住等短信，或者还是会想，这段关系接下来还会有什么发展？我太高兴你提到等短信这件事了，因为我觉得我们在讨论这个公式时，把皮质醇也讨论进去真的非常重要，因为你说得对，我们的催产素正在飙升，因为我们的身体在进行肢体上的建立亲密感，它以为我们会建立更深厚的连接，
these expectations of bonding so that's rising but then also what can be rising in the next few days afterwards is the cortisol which is the stress hormone right because if you are stressed and you leave and you're waiting for them to text you waiting for them to call you maybe you did something that you didn't want to do. Maybe you took things a little bit faster and you wish you'd taken things a bit slower. The stress hormone cortisol is going to be flooding through your body too. And I think that also if you have an anxious attachment style, and I'm not sure how much you talk about attachment styles, but I talk about them all the time because it's something that, you know, understanding my attachment style helped me understand myself so much better. But that can help you understand why the next few days
这种对亲密连接的期待在上升，但随后在接下来的几天里，上升的还有皮质醇，也就是压力荷尔蒙，对吧？因为如果你感到压力，离开之后你在等他们给你发短信，等他们给你打电话，也许你做了自己其实不想做的事，也许你的进展有点太快了，你希望当时能慢一点。压力荷尔蒙皮质醇也会在你的体内激增。而且我觉得，如果你有焦虑型依恋风格，虽然我不确定你们讨论依恋风格有多少，但我一直在谈论它们，因为这是一个，你知道的，理解我自己的依恋风格能让我更好地理解自己。但这可以帮你理解为什么接下来的几天
can be really, really stressful, even if you enjoyed the hookup in the moment. Because I think what we're saying is we're not saying like, oh, you know, we hate every second of the hookup. Like, no, we enjoy the hookup sometimes. You know, the hookup can be really fun. It can be really exhilarating. It's sometimes just the space after the hookup, the emptiness, like you said, but also the slightly tight feeling in your chest and you're looking at their phone.
可能会非常非常压力山大，哪怕你在当时很享受这次露水姻缘。因为我觉得我们的意思是，我们并不是说，哦，你知道，我们讨厌那次约会的每一秒。不，有时我们确实很享受这种关系。你知道，这种随性的关系真的可以很有趣，可以非常令人兴奋。有时只是约会之后的空间、空虚感，就像你说的，还有胸口那种微微发紧的感觉，然后你看着他们的手机。
Yeah. Yeah. Your phone, their WhatsApp, you know, they're online. They're not texting me back, like, oh, why did I do that? Like, I shouldn't have done that. And that's when you can also be flooded with cortisol. And it's just not a nice feeling. So I think you're right.
对，对。你的手机，他们的WhatsApp，你知道的，他们在线。他们没有回我短信，就像，哦，我为什么要做那种事？就像，我不该那样做的。而这就是你也会被皮质醇淹没的时候。这种感觉真的很不好。所以我觉得你说得对。
Just having compassion and grace for ourselves in understanding that so many of these feelings are working at a neurotransmitter level that we can just understand this is our biology at play here. And I think it can help us understand these intense feelings just a little bit more. And I love that you brought up cortisol because I think that that is such a valuable part of that kind of equation and that interaction
只要对我们自己多一些同情和宽容，理解许多这种感觉都是在神经递质的层面起作用，我们就能明白这只是我们的生理机制在发挥作用。我觉得这能帮我们更多地理解这些强烈的情感。我很高兴你提到了皮质醇，因为我觉得这是这种方程式以及在我们大脑中发生的这种互动中非常宝贵的一部分。
that's happening in our brain. The other one is the oxytocin crash. So oxytocin is like it's triggered often by intimate relations. Like I said, it could be triggered by like getting a massage from, you know, seeing a really beautiful tree of the ocean. I don't know. Anything that brings you joy. But the thing is that in those instances,
另一个就是催产素的断崖式下跌。所以催产素就像是，它通常是由亲密关系触发的。就像我说的，它也可能通过比如接受按摩，你知道的，看到一棵非常美丽的树或大海来触发。我不知道。任何能给你带来快乐的事物。但问题是，在那些情况下，
where it is something like a little bit less intense, something that might actually be more common as well, something that doesn't also have some of that taboo associated with it. And, you know, there's a difference between having casual sex with someone and seeing the ocean. It brings up different feelings, obviously. But those, like, those kind of activities, it's not so much of a spike. It's just this like gradual peak and then plateau. And it feels really, really lovely. It's like when you eat a banana, when you're really hungry and you get those like natural levels of like glucose and sugar. But it's like if you eat like a massive bag of candy and you haven't eaten like any sugar for like a couple of weeks and you're just like stuffing your face with it and you're like,
如果是那种强度稍微低一点的东西，某种可能实际上也更常见的东西，某种没有伴随着那么多禁忌感的东西。而且，你知道的，和某人发生随性关系和看大海是不一样的。这显然会带来不同的感觉。但那些活动，它不会产生那么大的峰值。它只是一种逐渐达到顶峰然后趋于平稳的过程。这种感觉真的非常好。就像当你真的很饿时吃一根香蕉，然后你获得了那种天然水平的葡萄糖和糖分。但这就好像你吃了一大袋糖果，而且你已经有好几个星期没吃任何糖了，然后你就像是在往嘴里狂塞糖果，你会觉得，
yes, you're going to have this sugar high, right? You're going to feel amazing. You're going to be like, yes, I want to eat candy all the fucking time. Like, yeah, like, how? high on life, literally like buzzing. That's literally what oxytocin does. It's like it's the same kind of neurotransmitter drug receptor that's used in a lot of illicit substances as well. So it's also something to note. But we have this crash.
太棒了，你的血糖会飙升，对吧？你会感觉好极了。你会觉得，耶，我他妈的想一直吃糖！就像，耶，就像，简直飘飘欲仙，整个人都在亢奋。这简直就是催产素的作用。这就好比很多非法物质中也会用到的一种相同的神经递质药物受体。所以这也是需要注意的一点。但我们会有这种断崖式下跌。
We have this crash, this come down, especially when the oxytocin isn't prolonged by things like aftercare or things like, and for those of you who don't know what aftercare, it's like having a cuddle after you've hooked up with someone or. doing something that engages in that pleasurable part of your brain, but has more to do with bonding and comfort and security and safety. So if that's not sustained, what we're going to see is that really intense crash. Do you have something to say about that? I feel like that's something that you could probably speak to as well.
我们会经历这种崩溃、这种情绪低落，尤其是当催产素没有通过诸如事后关怀（aftercare）之类的事情来延长时。或者对于那些不知道什么是事后关怀的人来说，这就好比和你发生关系后依偎在一起，或者做一些能调动你大脑中那个快乐区域，但更多地与亲密连接、安慰、安全感相关的事情。所以，如果这种状态没有持续下去，我们就会看到非常剧烈的崩溃。你有什么想说的吗？我觉得这也是你可以说上一说的话题。
Yeah, I'm just so happy you said the word aftercare because it's something that's still not spoken about much, but is so, so important. I think their studies showing that if there is aftercare involved in a sexual encounter, it changes the entire way that you process and experience the encounter. And something as simple as a cuddle, an intimate encounter, a conversation after that hookup can change the whole experience and help you, like, wean off the crash almost. And I think I'm probably not alone in that moment that, you know, it's finished.
对，我太高兴你说了“事后关怀”这个词了，因为这是一件仍然没有被充分讨论，但却极其重要的事情。我想有研究表明，如果性接触中包含事后关怀，它会改变你处理和体验这种经历的整个方式。像依偎、亲密的接触、约会后的谈话这样简单的事情，就能改变整个体验，几乎能帮你平稳度过这种情绪崩溃。我想在那一刻我大概不是唯一的孤单的人，你知道的，结束了，
maybe they roll over, they pick up their phone, maybe they just jump and get in the shower on their own. And you're just like lying there and you're alone. And for me, like, oh, I can feel the emotion now. Like I've been in that situation so many times. You're just like, oh, like you're not going to start, well, maybe you will start crying there. And if you do, that's absolutely okay
也许他们转过身去，拿起手机，也许他们直接跳下床自己去洗澡。而你只是躺在那里，孤零零的。对我来说，哦，我现在能感受到那种情绪了。我经历过太多次那种情况了。你就会觉得，哦，你可能不会开始，好吧，也许你真的会在那里哭起来。如果你真的哭了，那完全没问题，
because it's like a release of emotion. But it's definitely like a, oh, you know, they've got up, they've left. Maybe they just go and take a phone call. head to the kitchen, whatever it is that they do, I just think that that aftercare piece is so important. And if you are engaging in a hookup, I would say, don't be ashamed to say, like, I'm so excited to do this. But it's really important for me that, you know, we can have a cuddle afterwards. Like it elevates the whole, like the whole experience for me. And I think it's just about delivering that.
因为这就像是一种情绪的释放。但这绝对是一种，哦，你知道的，他们起床了，他们离开了。也许他们只是去接个电话，走到厨房，无论他们做什么，我都觉得事后关怀这部分太重要了。如果你要进行一次随性的约会，我会说，不要羞于表达，比如，我很期待这么做。但对我来说真的很重要的是，你知道，我们事后可以抱一抱。这提升了整体的体验，对我来说是整个体验的升华。我觉得这只是如何表达的问题。
Like we said, everything here is sex positive. Just deliver it in a positive way. Like I always love saying it would help me elevate the experience. Because it's like, that's so cool. It's something that they can do. really easy that can help develop the experience even more for you. They should want to do that for you, right?
就像我们说的，这里的一切都是性积极的。只需以积极的方式表达出来。就像我总是喜欢说的那样，这会帮我提升体验。因为这真的很酷。这是他们可以做到的、非常简单的一件事，却能进一步为你带来更美妙的体验。他们应该愿意为你这么做，对吧？
If they get access to you, your time, your energy, your emotions, your body, and you say to them like, hey, I'd love to have a cuddle. If they don't want to do that, if they won't give you that, I think it says everything about the hookup and that they probably don't deserve to be hooking up with you again. Oh yeah, it makes it seem so transactional, doesn't it? Right.
如果他们能够接触到你、你的时间、你的能量、你的情绪、你的身体，而你对他们说，嘿，我很想抱一抱。如果他们不愿意这样做，如果他们不肯给你这个，我觉得这说明了关于这次约会的一切，而且他们可能根本不配再和你约会了。哦，对，这让一切看起来太像一场交易了，不是吗？没错。
You're like, wow, I feel like we just, you know, exchange cash decisions. supermarket like I've had that experience before and I remember just being like wow I've never felt more empty in my life I was like and it was so sad and I remember being like to myself like I'm never going to have that experience ever again that is not for me much more selective now I would say but also just like I think this kind of links to what I really want to talk to you about next which is we're obviously most of us in our 20s or I would say yeah I would say the most of majority of us are having sex and probably having some form of casual sex or casual intimacy,
你会觉得，哇，我觉得我们刚刚，你知道的，完成了一场现金交易，就像在超市一样。我以前有过这种经历，我记得当时就觉得，哇，我这辈子从来没有感到如此空虚过。我当时想，这太让人伤心了。我记得当时对自己说，我再也不会有这种经历了，这不适合我。现在我会更有选择性，但我还觉得，这某种程度上和我接下来真正想跟你聊的话题联系在一起，那就是我们显然大多数人在20多岁，或者可以说，是的，我可以说我们中的绝大多数人都有过性行为，并且可能在经历某种形式的随性性行为或随性亲密关系，
if that's where you're at in your life right now. And I think something that's not spoken about much is, you know, we talk, people give a lot of relationship advice, right? Like there's so much, so many podcasts, so many articles, so many TikToks, so much information about there, out there around how to have a healthy, long-term, stable relationship. But not so many about, how to have a healthy hookup. So what's some of the advice that you would give? What some of the things that you would, because you obviously have such great language and dialogue around this, I feel like it needs to be, to be shared. Oh, bless you. Thank you. So yeah, the first one that we've already spoken about, I would say, is just knowing your truth. And I think that you need to understand
如果你现在的生活正处于这个阶段的话。我觉得有一件事没有被充分讨论，那就是，你知道的，我们谈论，人们给出了很多关于关系的建议，对吧？比如有这么多的播客，这么多的文章，这么多的TikTok，有那么多关于如何维系一段健康、长期、稳定关系的信息。但关于如何拥有的健康随性约会的却不多。那么你会给出什么建议呢？你有什么样的建议，因为你显然在这方面有非常出色的语言表达和对话能力，我觉得这些应该被分享出来。哦，谢谢你。谢谢。所以，是的，我们已经谈过的第一点，我要说的是，了解你内心的真实想法。我觉得你需要去理解
and connect with yourself before the hookup even starts, because you can't really decide it in the moment, because like we've said, there's so many neurotransmitters flying around that sometimes that will impair our judgment. So the first one is just understanding where you're at in your life right now, what you want and just agreeing some boundaries around that, you know, saying to yourself,
并在约会开始前就与自己建立连接，因为你无法在当时那一刻做出决定，因为就像我们说过的，有太多的神经递质在飞舞，有时这会影响我们的判断。所以第一点就是了解你目前的生活状态，你想要什么，并围绕此达成一些界限，你知道的，对自己说，
I'm just going to commit that I'm going to stick within these boundaries because I know that this is going to make me feel better in the long run. So yeah, the first one is knowing your truth. The second one, like I've said, is communication. And it feels awkward to have this communication
我只是承诺自己会坚守这些底线，因为我知道从长远来看这会让我感觉更好。所以，是的，第一点是了解你内心的真实想法。第二点，就像我所说的那样，是沟通。而进行这种沟通有时会觉得有点尴尬，
sometimes before a hookup, particularly if we don't know them very well, which is often where I find that this hookup culture sits. But I think it's just about practicing really small like sound bites of communication. You don't need to sit them down and say this is my backstory. This is my sex story. This is what I've gone through. So this is what I want from you. Like it doesn't need to, doesn't need to be like that. I think it's just about starting to have small dialogues around saying, I'm really excited to hook up with you. You know, I prefer to take things slower whilst I get to know you.
尤其是在约会之前，特别是如果我们对对方不是很了解的话，而我发现约会文化往往就存在于这种情况下。但我认为这只是关于练习非常小段的沟通。你不需要让他们坐下来听你讲这是我的背景故事，这是我的性爱史，这是我经历过的，所以这就是我对你的要求。这不需要，不需要是那样的。我觉得这只是关于开始进行一些小的对话，比如，我很期待和你约会。你知道的，在更好地了解你之前，我更喜欢慢慢来。
So maybe the first few times we hang out like, you know, we could just get to know. each other. If you want to slow things down with them, say that. If you don't and you want to go right into it, communicate with that with them. You know, right now I'm not looking for a relationship. So for me, this is just going to be a hookup and I'm really excited. How do you feel about that? Because, you know, we're coming at this from our angle as women. But actually, it might be that they want or don't want a relationship. So just having that light touch point, I think is really important. and I guess, you know, after the communication also brings us to the point of consent, which I think consent is the sexiest thing in the world,
所以也许我们刚开始见面的几次，你知道的，我们可以先互相了解一下。如果你想放慢节奏，那就说出来。如果你不想，只想直接进入正题，那就把你的想法传达给他们。你知道的，现在我不在寻找恋爱关系。所以对我来说，这只是一次约会，我真的很兴奋。你对此有什么看法？因为，你知道的，我们是从女性的角度出发来看待这件事的。但实际上，对方可能也想要或不想要一段关系。所以只需有这样一个轻松的切入点，我认为非常重要。我想，你知道的，沟通之后也会把我们带到同意（consent）这一点上，我认为同意是世界上最性感的事情，
and I can't wait, I can't wait until the world catches up with that belief that it should be the sexiest part of the conversation. You know, I want to do this with you. How do you feel about that? Oh, it's kind of, but like Louise, it kind of is so hot. Like when a guy's like, is this nice? And you're like, thank you so much for asking me that. Honestly, I, I, I, when I was.
我迫不及待，我迫不及待地想看到世界赶上这种信念，即这应该是对话中最性感的部分。你知道的，我想和你一起做这件事。你觉得怎么样？哦，这有点，但是路易斯，这真的很火辣。就像当一个男生说，这样感觉好吗？告诉我我可以做些什么不同。或者像，他说，这样感觉好吗？告诉我你想让我做什么，这样感觉会更好。而我当时就想，这是第一个在卧室里这样跟我沟通的男生，因为，哇。就像约会都是无声的，对吧？我们不，是的。而我喜欢，我简直爱上他了。我当时想，哦，天哪，你，你太不可思议了。所以我也很喜欢这样。我只是觉得不要对此感到羞耻。只要在卧室里勇敢表达自己。
like 20, I swear, this guy asked me when we were hooking up, he said, does that feel good for you? Tell me what I can do differently. Or like, he said, does this feel good for you? Tell me what you want me to do so it can feel even better. And I was just like, this was the first guy that had ever like communicated to me in the bedroom because, wow. Like hookups are silent, right? We don't, yeah. And I like, I like fell in love with him literally. I was like, oh my God, like you are, you are incredible. So I love it as well. I just think like don't be ashamed of it. Just be like use your voice in the bedroom.
哪怕你必须从非常小的细节开始。哦，是的，绝对的。而且我认为这也是一个非常棒的、几乎可以说是极佳的筛选系统，能让你明白你是否想和这个人继续发展下去。我们在这一整集中显然都提到过的一点是，你知道的，约会并不总是意味着发生完全的性交，
Like even if you have to start really small. Oh yeah, absolutely. And I think also it's such a great kind of like almost it's such a great vetting system to understand where you want to go with this person. Something that we've obviously said throughout this episode is, you know, hookups don't always mean having full blown intercourse and. having sex like it doesn't always mean that so if you're at like that first stage where you've like you know made out with someone at a party like having that kind of like conversation um to be like
发生性关系，它并不总是意味着那个。所以如果你处于那种最初的阶段，比如你在派对上和某人亲热了，进行那种类型的对话，去弄清楚，
oh where is this going like what does this feel like is like so so valuable gets you on the same page um and also just like make sure that you're able to be like okay this person just got out of a long-term relationship. Am I going to be a rebound? If that's, maybe that's like, maybe that's your specialty. All power to you. Like, maybe you have that healing energy. Love it. But maybe you're like, I don't need to deal with that emotional baggage. Let's move on. And it's also like a really good way of like determining like if they are respectful of that conversation, maybe you do want to move forward. If they're not, that's a really great place to end things when you're having a discussion around boundaries, barriers, history, if you are having that, or consent.
哦，这在往哪里发展？这感觉如何？真的非常非常有价值，能让你们达成共识，而且也能确保你能察觉到，比如“这个人刚结束一段长期关系。我会成为备胎吗？”如果那是，也许那就是你的特长。那祝你一切顺利。也许你自带这种疗愈能量。太棒了。但也许你会想，我不需要去应付那些情感包袱。我们还是算了吧。这也是一种很好的方式，去判断他们是否尊重这种对话，也许你真的想继续发展下去。如果他们不尊重，那当你讨论边界、保护措施、过往经历（如果你在讨论这些的话）或同意时，这绝对是一个结束关系的绝佳契机。
Like, it's such a great place to start, right? You can learn so much about someone. Yeah, and I think also just on that point, like, I love this quote, which is basically something along the lines of, are you using sex as the honey or the glue? Like, are you using it as something, yeah, to try and get them to like you, to love you, to be interested in you. Like when I was younger, I would lead with the sex and then hope they'd fall for me. Hope they'd decide they want a relationship.
这真的是一个很好的切入点，对吧？你能从一个人身上了解到很多。是的，我也想顺着这一点说，我非常喜欢这样一句话，它大致的意思是，你把性爱当作蜂蜜还是胶水？你是把它当作一种东西，是的，试图让他们喜欢你、爱你、对你感兴趣？当我年轻的时候，我会先发生性关系，然后希望他们会爱上我，希望他们会决定想要一段关系，
Hope they'd decide like, oh, hey, this chick's cool. Like, I'm up for hanging out with her again. But what I've learned as I've got older is that it should actually be the other way around. Like you build the foundations of something and then you use the sex as like the add-on. Like, okay, yeah, we're now going to have this incredible, pleasurable, powerful hookup. And I just think it's so interesting to ask like, oh, yeah, like, am I? I leading with this hookup hoping for something more or am I leading with this hookup because actually all I want is a hookup and again it ties back to the first point that I said what's your
希望他们会觉得，哦，嘿，这个女孩很酷，我很乐意再和她一起出去玩。但我随着年龄增长所学到的是，事情其实应该反过来。你应该先建立某些事情的基础，然后把性爱当作一种附加项。就像，好吧，是的，我们现在要进行一次令人难以置信的、愉悦的、充满力量的约会。我觉得问这样一个问题非常有趣，哦，是的，我是不是带着想要更多东西的期许去进行这次约会，还是说我进行这次约会是因为实际上我想要的就只是一次约会？这又回到了我说的第一点，你的真实想法是什么？
truth then you can be empowered then you can communicate it and then you can go with it and have an amazing experience of whatever that looks like. Oh wise words from a wise woman. One more question because I just feel like we have to just quickly talk about this. Yes. Because we've talked about how sometimes you know there are these studies that have been done that show kind of an emotional response that isn't always positive. Sometimes it's regret, sometimes it's embarrassment. Any advice for what to do then? You can't take back what's been done.
然后你就能重获力量，然后你就能进行沟通，然后你就可以顺其自然，去体验无论那是什么样子的美妙经历。智者的睿智之言。还有一个问题，因为我觉得我们必须快速讨论一下这个。是的。因为我们讨论过有时，你知道，已经有一些研究表明了一种并不总是积极的情感反应。有时是后悔，有时是尴尬。对于那种情况有什么建议吗？你无法收回已经做过的事。
Sometimes it can leave you in a place where you just feel really worthless and useless and gross about yourself. So where do you go from there? What do you think your perspective on that is? Yes. So what I love here is understanding the difference in the concepts of like regret versus is shame and I'm sure you've touched on this a lot in your podcast but for me they're very different things the the regret is about a specific act or experience whereas the shame is about us so something
有时这会让你陷入一种觉得自己一文不值、毫无用处并且对自己感到恶心的境地。所以从那里你该何去何从？你对这种事的看法是什么？是的。所以我喜欢这里的一点是，理解“后悔”与“羞耻”这两个概念的区别，我确信你在你的播客中经常谈到这一点，但对我来说它们是非常不同的东西。后悔是针对某个特定的行为或经历，而羞耻则是关于我们自己——某种
like about the core of our being so the regret can be something like oh I regret having intercourse with them I regret hooking up with them I regret having sex with them like I wish I hadn't done it that soon but the shame is deeper it's I shouldn't have done that because I gave my body away. I'm not worthy. Like I'm dirty. I'm empty. Like they go a lot deeper. So they're both really difficult emotions to deal with, but I would definitely just start with understanding that differentiation. And that can then help you understand what comes next. Because if it's just regret, you can be like, okay, why am I regretful? Okay, because I was drunk, because I was high, because I had, you know, I did something that I didn't want to do that I wouldn't have done if I was
关于我们核心本质的东西。所以后悔可能是这样的，哦，我很后悔和他们发生性关系，我很后悔跟他们约会，我很后悔和他们发生关系，我希望自己没有那么快做这件事。但羞耻感更深，它是：我不该那样做，因为我把身体交出去了，我不配，我很脏，我很空虚。它们要深刻得多。所以这两种都是非常难处理的情感，但我绝对会从理解这种区别开始。然后这可以帮你理解接下来会发生什么。因为如果只是后悔，你可以想，好吧，我为什么会后悔？好吧，因为我喝醉了，因为我嗑药了，因为我有，你知道的，我做了一些自己其实不想做的事，如果我处在
a state of mind, in a different state of mind. You can be like, okay, cool. Next time, when I see this person, I'm not going to drink, or I'm going to drink less at the next party, or I'm not going to smoke, or whatever that is. You can just make some, like, really rational decisions to change and reduce the likelihood of the regret. Now, with the shame, it goes a lot deeper, and I think that's something where therapy can just be so helpful to work through, because sometimes your friends can help you process the regret but it's really like a therapist that can help you process the shame you know where did that come from yeah where did that develop so i think my first point here is like understanding that difference in regret and shame can really help you like navigate what comes next
不同的心境下，我是绝不会那样做的。你可以想，好吧，酷。下次我见到这个人时，我不喝酒了，或者我在下次派对上少喝一点，或者我不抽烟了，无论那是什么。你可以做出一些非常理性的决定来改变并减少后悔的可能性。至于羞耻感，它要深得多，我觉得那是心理治疗可以发挥巨大作用的地方，因为有时你的朋友可以帮你度过后悔，但真的需要治疗师来帮你处理羞耻感，你知道的，那根源于哪里？是的，那是怎么产生的？所以我觉得我的第一点是，理解后悔和羞耻的区别真的可以帮你在接下来找到方向，
and navigate those really difficult feelings and is it a question of self-worth as well i think that that is a massive component and a massive emotional component of of casual sex is self-worth, something that we could do probably a whole new, a whole other deep dive on it. But it's not something that's going to be, I think, healed overnight. I think also we have a habit of sometimes suppressing unpleasant emotions, which isn't really going to help you on the long run, because if you have left something casual, if you've left to hook up feeling really bad about yourself, doing that again, it might be, might make the situation worse or it might put you back into this place of spiraling in this place of shame.
并应付那些非常困难的情感。这也是一个关于自我价值的问题吗？我认为这是随性性关系中一个极其重要的组成部分，一个巨大的情感组成部分，那就是自我价值，我们可能可以围绕这个话题做一个全新的、深入的探讨。但这并不是那种，我认为，能在一夜之间被治愈的事情。而且我觉得我们有时有一种压抑令人不愉快的情绪的习惯，从长远来看，这实际上对你没有任何帮助，因为如果你在一段随性关系结束后，如果你带着对自己极差的感觉离开，再次这样做，可能会让情况变得更糟，或者可能会让你重新陷入这种在羞耻感中恶性循环的境地。
So addressing it head on and actually taking time to process the shame like you spoke about, the deeper emotional response and reaction that you're having will definitely benefit you in the long run rather than running away from the feeling, hiding from the feeling, suppressing the feeling. Yeah, I think it's so important your point around suppressing and then the ongoing. going cycles because if you don't process the uncomfortable emotions you just push them down and then what happens oh it gets to the weekend you go out again you get drunk again and the same cycles they just repeat and that was me you know for so many years of partying in my early 20s it would almost be like every weekend I'd do something well not every weekend that's like that's like a lot of hookups it wasn't
所以直面它，并真正花时间去处理羞耻感——正如你所说的那样，你正在经历的更深层次的情感反应——从长远来看，绝对会让你受益，而不是逃避这种感觉、隐藏这种感觉、压抑这种感觉。是的，我觉得你关于压抑以及随后陷入持续循环的观点非常重要，因为如果你不处理那些不舒服的情绪，你只是把它们压下去，然后会发生什么呢？哦，到了周末，你又出去了，又喝醉了，同样的循环不断重复。而那正是我，你知道的，在20多岁刚出头时疯狂聚会了好多年的真实写照。几乎每个周末我都会做一些，好吧，也不是每个周末，那听起来像是有超级多的约会，其实并没有那么多约会，但那会是，你知道的，做一些我后悔的事情的循环，然后不得不去应付那些后果。所以关于去感受情绪这一点，你真的说得太对了。我觉得不压抑那一部分是一个更长期的过程，学会去感受，学会去处理。这真是一段旅程。我比你大得多，我至今仍在学习如何去感受和处理情绪。就像今天早上我们连线之前，我看了个视频，讲几头大象陷在泥里，大象妈妈用鼻子护着小象。然后我就想哭，我就对自己说，别这么傻。然后我又想，不，哭吧，如果你真的很难过，觉得它们会一起死在那里，
like that many hookups but it would be you know cycles of doing things I regret and then and then having to deal with the repercussions. So you're so right about just feeling. And I think that not suppressing piece is like a longer term piece, like learning how to feel, learning how to process. Like it's a journey. I'm way older than you. I'm still learning how to process and feel. Like this morning before we came on here, I like watched a video of these elephants like stuck in the mud. And the, and the mom was like covering the baby with her trunk. And I was like, I want to cry. And I was like, don't be so stupid. And I was like, and I was like, like no cry like if if you're really sad that they thought they were going to die there together and
而且大象妈妈还有……你知道吗，我作为一个30多岁的女人，就站在自己的卧室里，看着这些大象哭得稀里哗啦。我就觉得，这就是在做功课啊。这些微小的时刻，当我们在Instagram快拍上看到一头大象就想哭时，这就是在做功课，就是这些小事，对吧？我觉得这适用于一切，当你感到负面情绪、复杂情绪、微妙情绪、含糊不清的情绪时，你最不应该做的事情其实就是不去面对它们，不去真正保持对你自己的感受、你对某种情况的反应的觉察。这样一来，你知道的，当我们再次谈论随性性关系时，如果这可能不适合你，你可不想在三年后才弄明白这一点，然后不得不去应付所有这些“如果当初”以及，我猜在这个例子中，就是后悔和羞耻。如果你能真正直面自己的情绪，并能够在当下处理好它们，这对你来说会有益得多。显然，这是一门需要时间去学习的。不幸的是，我们并没有为你准备什么检查清单。那可太值钱了。我们真该把那个整理出来。对，我们真的应该。
the mom was like had oh and do you know what I stood in my bedroom as a 30 something you're a woman I just bawled my eyes out over these elephants and I was like this is this is doing the work these tiny moments where we want to cry over an elephant on an Instagram story it's doing the work it's the little things right and it is something that I think applies to everything when you feel negative emotions when you feel complicated emotions, nuanced emotions, ambiguous emotions, the worst thing you can do is actually not sit with them and really stay in touch with how you feel, how you're responding to a situation so that, you know, when we talk about casual sex again, like if it's something that maybe isn't for you, you don't want to figure that out like
下一次合作。对，完全如此。我觉得这里另一个非常非常重要的话题是，既然我们已经谈论了更长期的部分，比如羞耻、后悔、压抑。我觉得同样重要的一点是，理解在约会后的24、48、72小时内你可以做些什么，来帮助平复催产素的断崖式下跌，缓解皮质醇的飙升。而且我发现，通常在那些我感到后悔的约会之后，我会感觉非常冷漠，就像我治疗师所描述的那种情感上的冷漠，还有恐惧和后悔，
three years down the track and then have to deal with like all of these what ifs and all of I guess in this instance, regret and shame, it'd be so much more beneficial to you if you really sat with your emotions and were able to process them in the moment. Obviously, it's something that you learn over time. We don't have like a checklist for you, unfortunately. That would be worth a lot of money. But we should put that together. Yeah, we really should.
而且我感觉真的很不好。我会有种只想将自己孤立起来的感觉，
Next collab. Yeah, exactly. I think another thing that's really, really important to talk about here is like we've spoken about the longer term piece, like the shame, regret, suppress. I think what's also so important is like understanding what you can do in the 24, 48, 72 hours after the hookup to help that oxytocin crash, to help that cortisol spike. And I think that what I've found is often after hookups that I regretted, I'd feel very cold, like emotionally cold is how my therapist describes it and fearful and regretful. and I just would not feel good. I would kind of just want to isolate myself
或者走向另一个极端，再次出去狂欢。所以我觉得关键在于真正去承认：好吧，我感觉不好。在接下来的24、48、72小时内，我能做些什么来帮助平衡这些神经递质？对我和其他人来说，你知道的，人们会说，哦，你不应该靠在沙发上看网飞吃披萨来麻痹自己。但对我和很多人来说，那确实是第二天我能做的最好的事情，
or I'd go the other way and just go out partying again. So I think it's about really acknowledging like, okay, I don't feel good. What can I do in the next 24, 48, 78, 72 hours to help balance those neurotransmitters. So for me, it's, you know, they say that, oh, you shouldn't numb on the sofa with a Netflix and a pizza. But for me, that is the best thing that I can do that next day
那就是在傍晚时分，感受温暖，泡个澡，穿上非常舒服的睡衣，看一部轻松快乐的电影，吃披萨，吃点温暖的、感觉有点像“罪恶慰藉”的东西。然后早点睡，我总是说，经过一个晚上的好觉，第二天什么事情都变得更容易应付了。
is to be, like in the evening, to be warm, to have a bath, to put on some really comfy pajamas, to watch a really easy movie that's happy, to have a pizza, like, have something that's, like, warm and feels a bit naughty. And then to have an early night, like, I always say everything is more manageable the next day, like, after a good night's sleep.
所以如果你那天正经历可怕的情绪，如果你想给他们发短信，好吧，写在你的便签里，写下来。是的。是的，把你想要说的话写下来，我会说，这不叫压抑。我只是说，先放上24小时。我向你保证，当你第二天睡了个好觉，
So if you are feeling horrible emotions that day, and if you want to text them, okay, write it in your notes, write down. Yes. Yeah, what you want to say, and I say, this isn't suppression. I just say, leave it 24 hours. And I guarantee you that when you come back to that note, the next day, after a good night's sleep,
在酒精、药物或任何参与这次经历的东西的药效消退之后，当你重新看到那条便签时。在情绪开始平复之后，你会看着那条信息，也许，如果你像我一样，你会想，谢天谢地，
after the alcohol or the drugs or whatever it is that, you know, has been involved in this encounter, has worn off. After the crash is starting to come down, you'll look at that message. And maybe, like, if you're like me, you'll be like, thank goodness. I didn't say.
我没有把那条信息发出去。就像，哦，天哪。然后你可以在48到72小时的时候，在感觉更平衡一点、更平静一点、更被关爱一点的时候去处理它。你可以给他们发短信说：谢谢你那天晚上的陪伴，那引发了我一些不舒服的情绪，
that message. Like, oh my goodness. And then you can navigate it in the 48 to 72 hour mark when you're feeling a little bit more balanced, a little bit more calm, a bit more cared for. You can text them and you can say, appreciate your time the other night. It brought up some uncomfortable emotions for me.
所以我觉得这不是我想再次和你发生的情况。但我确实觉得你很棒，你超级帅，我玩得很开心。你知道，也许就这样结束了。或者无论你的真实想法是什么，
So I don't think this is a situation that I want to do with you again. But I do think you're great. You're super handsome. Like I had so much fun. You know, maybe that's it. You end it there. Or whatever your true,
无论你的真实想法是什么，我觉得你都可以发一条温和的信息。这样你就不是沉默，也不是压抑。我觉得在约会后的72小时窗口期里，你可以想：好吧，在这段时期内我能做什么来让自己感觉好一点？因为对于那些把约会看得糟糕的人来说，这段时间会让你感觉最糟。我会说，我有一个诀窍，每当我为某事感到极度情绪化，而我的第一本能是想要立即在当下说点什么来发泄我的愤怒、释放我的情绪时，
whatever your truth is, I think you can just send a gentle message. So you're not silence. So you're not suppressed. And I think that that kind of 72-hour window after a hookup, you can be like, okay, what can I do in here that can make me feel better in the time that if you take hookups badly is going to make you feel the worst. And I'm going to say I do this tip. I do this trick where when I'm feeling super emotional about something and my first instinct is to like, say something immediately in the moment to have my, have my fury moment, to have my emotional outlet.
我把它写下来，或者写在手机便签里然后放在那不管。我一直等到自己头脑清醒。如果你是一个确实在随性性关系、约会文化的复杂情感和微妙之处中苦苦挣扎的人，这可能会非常非常重要。而且，向那些依然在听这个节目、心想“我爱随性性关系，我经常约会，我为此感到无比自豪”的人大声致敬，去吧，太棒了，去吧，去吧！你真的很幸运，因为我有时候
I write it down or I write it in my notes up and I just leave it. I wait until I have a clear head. And that's if you're someone who really does struggle with kind of the emotional complications and nuances of casual sex, of hookup culture, it might be really, really important. And, you know, shout out to the people who are still listening to this, who are like, I love casual sex. I hook up all the time. I am so proud of you like go yes go for it go for it you're you're very lucky that like I kind of
希望自己能成为那样的人。我想我曾长时间试图让自己成为那样的人，但我真的不是。所以，活出真实的自我，无论那意味着什么。就像你说的，路易斯！哦，我太喜欢这样了。我的感受也一样，你知道，如果那是你，我真是太羡慕了。我真希望自己能有更多这种轻松有趣的性经历。因为到了20多岁的时候我就想，我再也不能这样下去了。真的，从25岁开始，我基本上只和四个人发生过性关系，因为那之后我只和男朋友发生关系。
wish I could be that person I think I was trying to make myself that person for a long time but I'm just not so live your truth whatever that may be like you said Louise oh I love that and I feel the same you know if that's you I'm so envious like I wish like I could have had more just like fun sexual encounters because by the age of like 20s I was like, I can't do this anymore. Like I really, from the age of 25 onwards, I really slept with like four people because it was like I only slept with boyfriends thereafter.
有时候我在想，哦，在我20多岁的时候有五年时间，我本可以有更多这种放纵的乐趣。所以如果是你，请代我和杰玛好好享受吧。是的，拜托了。我们可没有你们那么常这样。我很喜欢这种状态。世界确实需要更多的赋权。如果你处于那种被赋权的状态，
And sometimes I was like, oh, I, there were five years in my 20s where like I could have had way more promiscuous fun. So if that's you, enjoy it for me and Gemma. Yes, please. We're not doing it as much as you. And I love it. We do need more empowerment in the world. And if you're in that empowered category,
感觉棒极了，你也很喜欢，那向你致敬，我太为你高兴了。是的，我是真心这么觉得的。就像那句话说的，对吧？被赋权的表现有时可能感觉并不那么具有赋权感，但如果它对你来说确实是赋权的，那就，向你致敬，致敬，致敬！是的，致敬。我以前真的从来没说过“致敬（kudos）”这个词，但，致敬！我知道，这是个美丽的词，不是吗？好吧，致敬。好吧，我想对路易斯说声致敬，感谢你来到节目中。看看这个，多么顺畅的过渡啊。我真心希望，如果你还在收听，你在精神上非常享受这一集。路易斯，非常感谢你的智慧和暖心的话语。哦，我的荣幸，我也很感激你允许我将自己真实生活的一部分带入你那些不可思议的、
it feels great for you, you love it, then kudos to you and I love that for you. Yeah, I honestly do. And it's like that saying, right, like what is empowerment might not always feel empowering, but if it is empowering to you, like, yeah, kudos, kudos, kudos. Yeah, kudos. I've literally never said the word kudos before, but kudos. I know. It's a beautiful word, isn't it? Well, kudos. Well, I want to say kudos to Louise, but coming on. Look at that. What a smooth transition that was. I really hope that if you're still listening, you have very mentally enjoyed this episode. Louise, thank you so much for your wisdom and your kind words. Oh, my pleasure, and I'm just grateful that you've allowed me to bring a bit of my real life into your incredible
以科学为基础的节目中。我觉得你为每个人提供了他们正好需要学习的东西，我就是喜欢这种带有人性温度和真实生活经验的小细节。所以能和你一起做这期节目我真的非常开心。非常谢谢你。是的，这真的太棒了，绝对是我最喜欢的节目之一。我顺便也要安利一下，如果你没有在听路易斯的播客《Open House podcast》，那它真的太不可思议了，太棒了。里面有非常多的讨论，就像这一集一样，你绝对应该去听一听。
science-backed episodes. I think you give everyone exactly what they need to learn, and I just love this little bit of human, human touch and lived experience. So I really love doing this with you. Thank you so much. Yeah, it was honestly amazing. And probably one of my favorite episodes. I will also just give you a plug. If you're not listening to Louise's podcast, the Open House podcast, it is incredible. It is amazing. There are so many discussions, much like this one, that are available there and that you should absolutely go and listen to.
如果你想开阔视野，想听到更多信息。我觉得这就是那种必须要发生的合作，这也是一期必须要播出的节目。所以再次非常感谢你。如果你喜欢这一集，请随时在苹果播客、Spotify或你现在正在收听的任何平台上留下五星好评。这真的对节目的成长和触达新听众非常有帮助。
If you want to expand your mind, you want to hear more information. I felt this was just the collab that needed to happen. and it was the episode that needed to happen. So thank you so much once again. And if you did enjoy this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. It really does help the show to grow and reach new people.
欢迎把这一集分享给可能需要听到它的朋友，你永远不知道谁会需要。如果你想更多地参与到我们的社群中，想知道接下来有什么内容、我们邀请了什么嘉宾、有什么周边等等，请在社交平台上关注@That Psychology Podcast，祝大家度过美好的一周。
Feel free to share this episode with a friend who might need to hear it. You never know. And if you want to be more involved with the community, you want to know what's coming up, what guests we have on the show, merch, things like that, please follow us at That Psychology Podcast and have a lovely, lovely week.
我们很快会带另一集回归。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）带来的《Learn the Hardway》。这个节目聚焦于黑男性的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方都实在不安全去进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个深谙此道的持证专业人士进行对话。
We will be back soon with another episode. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
有多少男人穿着铠甲？它向世界释放出一种信号：
How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world. that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
你不是好惹的。但仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你非得这么做。在AHA广播应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。“艾伦女士，你把这个特定的测试篡改了两次，对吧？”“我篡改了一次测试。”这需要一支由网络侦探组成的军队来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人——
Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%.
格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side
这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中。我剖析了坚韧意志、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的标志。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，
a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the I-HeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, They take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target.
成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即数字2和百分号，在I-HeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个高产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。
He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他休想就这样逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。收听《The Girlfriends. Trust me, babe.》。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个IHeart播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。